a transformation what do you think I
normally look like it's very much the
achy older self
older men when they get married you know
you you understand women more because
you're with them all the time but
teenage boys don't really get it as much
I don't think High School is a pleasant
experience for anybody it's so exciting
it's the most wounding time you could
ever have from the two-week press tour
of my press junket it's the same day as
my prom I have pants up aggression from
high school I really do grad Knight
graduation I was beat up on because I
didn't grow till the 12th grade I was I
was actually a law ornament until the
12th I mean it's just like this whole
world of amazing things